عندما يقول الناس أن هذه مجرد حملة أخرى ،
فما الذي
تقوله مرة أخرى ما هو مختلف عنها ، لذا
أعتقد أنه من الواضح أننا تعلمنا الكثير
من الحملات الأخرى التي تحدثنا إليها
معهم ، لقد ناقشناها
واستخدمنا ما فعلوه ولكني  أعتقد
أن الأمر المختلف في الجائزة هو
أنني أقول إنها تتعلق بهذا التفاؤل ، إنها
تتعلق بهذه الفكرة أنه يمكننا إيجاد
حلول ويمكننا قيادة التغيير على ما أعتقد بدلاً
من القول إن الأمر كله كئيب
، وفي الحقيقة لا يوجد شيء
يمكننا القيام به حيال ذلك
والعناوين الرئيسية التي لا نهاية لها من الانقراضات
والمشاكل للأسف بيئات حول
العالم
نريد أن نقول للناس الاستماع كما تعلم
على مدى السنوات العشر القادمة إذا تمكنا من تحديد
هذه الأهداف الطموحة وهذه الأهداف
وإلهام الناس للارتقاء إلى مستوى
التحدي ، فهناك أشخاص
رائعون يفعلون  أشياء لا تصدق حول العالم
كلها في مجتمعات صغيرة في كل مكان ، إذا
كان لدى أحدهم فكرة رائعة ،
فيمكننا توسيع نطاق ذلك ويمكننا استخدام ذلك
لمعالجة بعض المشكلات
التي تحدثت عنها حقًا  تطرقت إلى كيف
استوحيت في هذا العمل في البداية من
عمل والدك وجدك
رواد بلا شك في هذا المجال.
كيف ستقيس
نجاحك وكيف
تسمح للأمير جورج على سبيل المثال
أن يرث هذا كما قلت
بدأ جدي في القيام بأشياء تتعلق
بالحفظ منذ وقت طويل ،
خاصة
أن والدي كان قبل وقته يتحدث
عن تغير المناخ ، ولا أريد أن
أسبق وقتي
لأننا بعد ذلك قد فات الأوان والآن
حان وقت العمل
وينظر إليّ أنا وأولادي ويسألونني
الكثير من الأسئلة ، فهم يحبون
العالم الطبيعي ويريدون معرفة الإجابات
ويريدون معرفة سبب وجود الكثير من
السلبية ولماذا يشعر الجميع
بالقلق ومدى سوء
الأمر وأريد ذلك  استدر إليهم
وقل أن لدينا حلولًا يمكننا إيجاد طريقة من
خلال ذلك ، فأنت تعلم أن
براعة الإنسان وروح
الابتكار البشرية ضخمة ، نضع رجلاً على
القمر
يمكننا القيام بذلك ، كان نشأة هذا
قبل المقلاة  demic ،
فإن الوباء يصيب كيف يكون الوباء
مما رأيته
يؤثر على السبب الأوسع ، وهل يمكنك أن
تتعلم شيئًا من هذه العملية التي مررنا بها ،
من
الواضح أن كوفيد كان أمرًا مروعًا
جدًا للجميع
وفقدنا الكثير من الأشخاص  للأسف ،
أعتقد أن ما علمتنا إياه كوفيد هو
أنه النوع الأول من
الأوقات الصعبة
التي واجهها جيلي والأجيال الشابة بالتأكيد ، من
الواضح أن الأجيال الأكبر سناً قد
مرت بالحرب ولا يوجد شيء مثل
أنها كانت مروعة حقًا ولكن هذا
كان  وقت صعب للجميع ،
وقت صعب للغاية وأعتقد أنه
إذا كان هناك أي نوع من شعاع الضوء الصغير
الذي يمكن أن يخرج من هذا هو أن الناس
كانوا في الخارج أكثر
، لقد جربوا الطبيعة رأوها
، لقد سمعوا الطيور  نظرًا لأن
الطائرات
كانت أقل ، كانت الطرق
أكثر هدوءًا وآمل
أن يكون لدى الناس تلك اللحظة للتواصل وإدراك
مدى خصوصية
العالم الأخضر والطبيعي من
حولهم وهكذا  أعتقد أنه إذا تمكنا من العثور على المال
والتعاون
وقوة الإرادة للتعامل مع الطمع
كما فعلنا ، فيمكننا القيام بذلك من أجل
البيئة أيضًا